der wille länder der mission rosetta
bleibt stumm die nasa will einen
asteroiden zum mond bringen und ein
gigantischer meteoritenkrater in
australien wurde entdeckt dass er drei
der themen jetzt pünktlich zum treffen
muss
mission rosetta kein signal vom filet
der viele länder hat sich bislang nicht
mehr vom kometen 67 peter orloff
gerasimenko gemeldet die experten des
deutschen zentrums für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr hatten gehofft dass sich
die landeeinheit der raumsonde rosetta
aus dem standby modus heraus meldet die
kommunikationseinheit des senders wird
jetzt allerdings wieder abgeschaltet in
der ersten aprilhälfte soll ein neuer
anlauf gestartet werden mögliche
ursachen für das ausgebliebene signal
sind die kälte auf dem kometen oder auch
die fehlende sonneneinstrahlung wenn
durch die schatten die von den
umliegenden gesteinsbrocken geworfen
werden erreicht möglicherweise noch
nicht genug sonne nicht den länder auch
die entfernung zur sonne spielt dabei
eine rolle
es besteht aber auch die möglichkeit
dass viele schon aus seinem winterschlaf
erwacht ist seine energie jedoch nicht
ausreicht um ein signal zur erde zu
senden alles in allem wissen die
wissenschaftler nicht wo genau der
länder auf dem kometen steht zwar lassen
sich die bisher erhaltenen daten
auswerten und so topographien erstellen
wie genau diese aber sind ist ungewiss
der raumgleiter xv hat seinen testflug
erfolgreich absolviert
der testflug des in der entwicklung
stehenden welt raumgleiters xv ist
erfolgreich abgeschlossen worden
mit der hilfe von fallschirm landete das
raumschiff sicher im pazifik das ziel
der europäischen weltraumorganisation
esa ist dabei klar
der raumgleiter xv soll astronauten von
der erde ins all und wieder
zurückbringen können und das unabhängig
von russland oder den usa
zudem werden neue daten benötigt um ein
europäisches wieder verwendbares raum
fahrzeug zu entwickeln nach etwa 20
minuten löste sich das knapp fünf meter
lange raumschiff von der rakete der
aufstieg von ex frau war damit
allerdings noch nicht beendet die
trennung erfolgte 340 kilometer über der
erde
anschließend stieg das zwei tonnen
schwere raumschiff bis auf 450 kilometer
höhe auf mit dem testflug sollten
wichtige daten gesammelt werden die das
raumschiff weiter verbessern
besonders vom sinkflug versprechen sich
die wissenschaftler eine menge neue
daten
denn der
hitzeschild des raumgleiters musste bei
seinem wiedereintritt in den orbit bei
einer geschwindigkeit von 27.000
stundenkilometern temperaturen von etwa
1700 grad celsius trotzen
die auswertung der daten beginnt jetzt
wird sich laut angaben der esa auf bis
zu sechs wochen aus dem gigantischer
meteoritenkrater in australien entdeckt
forscher haben in australien die wohl
größten meteoritenkrater auf der erde
entdeckt entstanden ist der karte
anscheinend durch einen asteroiden der
sich selbst noch einmal zerteilt hat die
beiden gesteinsbrocken hatte einen
durchmesser von etwa zehn kilometern
rissen bei ihrem aufprall aber jeweils
löcher von 190 km durchmesser in die
erde
die krater reichten zudem in bis zu 20
kilometer tiefe ereignet hat sich dieses
dramatische ereignis vermutlich vor so
300 bis 600 millionen jahren
zusammengerechnet ergeben die karte eine
größere fläche als dieses chicxulub
krater auf der mexikanischen halbinsel
yucatan der mit dem aussterben der
dinosaurier verbunden dort dieser
entstand vor rund 65 millionen jahren
sein durchmesser beträgt etwa 180
kilometer im jahr 2013 wurde eines der
beiden löcher bei arbeiten für
geothermische bohrungen in queensland
entdeckt die genommenen bodenproben
diesen spuren von verglasten gestein auf
das ist ein anzeichen von extremen
temperaturen und drücken wie sie bei
einem meteoriteneinschlag auftreten eine
analyse der seismischen und magnetischen
signaturen des bogens in den anstalten
gebieten zeigte dann dass beide krater
von denselben methoden verursacht wurden
ob der meteoriteneinschlag in australien
zu einem massensterben geführt hat das
muss noch untersucht werden
ein asteroid kreist um den mond das hört
sich erst mal seltsam an aber ist
tatsächlich ein geplantes projekt der
nasa itokawa bänder oder 2008 e5 einer
dieser drei asteroiden soll genauer
unter die lupe genommen werden dazu soll
ein unbemanntes raumschiff einen teil
aus dem gesteinsbrocken herausschlagen
und anschließend in eine umlaufbahn des
mondes einsetzen damit könnte das
aktenmaterial einfacher untersucht und
vor allem auch von astronauten besucht
die so genannte ästhet redirect mission
soll die erforschung unseres weltraums
weiter vorantreiben
gestartet werden soll die mission im
dezember 2020 die gesamtkosten belaufen
sich auf lächerliche 1 25 milliarden
us-dollar
sobald ein asteroid ausgewählt wurde
werde dort von einer unbemannten
raumsonde ein stück von etwa vier metern
herausgeschlagen und abtransportiert der
längste zeitraum wird der transport des
us riesen stück zum mond er soll knapp
sechs jahre dauern wenn alles glatt
läuft werden 2025 zwei astronauten zum
aktuellen stück geschickt dort haben sie
dann 25 tage zeit um gegen
gesteinsbrocken genau zu untersuchen und
oben zu sammeln
curiosity findet einen weiteren hinweis
für leben auf dem mars der mars rover
curiosity hat spuren von nitrat auf dem
mars entdeckt die stickstoffverbindung
konnte in bodenproben des roten planeten
entdeckt werden entstanden ist das
nitrat vermutlich durch hitzeschocks bei
anschlägen oder blitzen schreiben die
wissenschaftler um jennifer stone vom
goddard space flight center der us
raumfahrtbehörde nasa
die neuen erkenntnisse deuten erneut
darauf hin dass der mars früher
lebensfreundlich gewesen sein könnte
denn die lebewesen auf der erde
benötigen stickstoff in chemische
fixierter form um moleküle zu bilden die
sie zum leben benötigen und so könnte es
auf dem mast auch gewesen sein sollte es
dort lebensform gegeben haben
der mars rover hatte deshalb gezielt in
den bodenproben des roten planeten nach
stickstoff gesucht und tatsächlich gehör
city konnte spuren von 70 bis 1100
teilchen nitrat pro million teilchen
entdecken und das sowohl im maßstab als
auch in einem potenziellen ehemaligen
see auf dem mars der bodengebundene
stickstoff könnte einen simplen
stickstoffkreislauf ermöglicht haben und
damit eine biochemisch zugängliche
stickstoff quelle darstellen und was
meint ihr
gibt es leben auf dem mars also leben
diese organismen vielleicht noch wenn es
sie gegeben hat das spricht dafür was
spricht dagegen diskutiert es wie immer
mit mir in den kommentaren die letzten
folgen der top five news findet ihr
hier in diesem video hat alles was er
über das super material carbon wissen
müsst alle links zu den einzelnen themen
stehen auch unten in der video
beschreibung und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran